[Music]
classic and vintage cars have a certain
elegance and style you just don't see
anymore and they've cast a spell of one
kind or another on their owners part of
it is the challenge a sense of adventure
the owners set out to experience the
full power of their darlings one way to
do it is with races and performance
tests
other classics fans put more value on
enjoyment and the finer things in life
the vintage car rallies were created for
them on drives like these the journey
itself is its own reward the route for
this year's ADAC LAN party classic led
through the Sprave odd and allows its
region south of berlin this was only the
second rally after it's auspicious 2016
premiere in the Lake District around
Reuben
[Music]
a DC's month would void confirms that
everyone's there to kick back and enjoy
they drive the vintage cars cross
country for an experience that combines
cultural attractions leisure and
automobile fun after all the ADAC
invented the concept of hiking by car
the close to 100 entries in the ADAC LAN
party classic draws crowds everywhere
they go it's like a parade of highlights
from 85 years of automotive art and the
drivers enjoy a stress-free trip to
beautiful countryside
[Music]
this man is glad they don't have to drag
out the roadmap and it's relaxing just
to follow the easy timetable his wife
points out that they have nothing to
argue about it but it is an always peace
love and harmony once in a while someone
has to let off some steam this man's
having trouble with his cooling system
you'll need the ADAC to help him out a
bit the short breaks are needed to keep
everyone in shape and together at least
the drivers don't have to worry about
points times and valuations the top
priority here is fun and some urbanites
are seeing parts of their country for
the first time this man has been to
nearby caught booze but never explored
its surroundings and or visited the
slave of UNESCO biosphere reserve now we
can appreciate the region's natural
beauty
[Music]
[Music]
the next break is at noid silla abbey
where participants present their cars in
all their glory to a jury of specialists
in the Concours d'Elegance
[Music]
but no vintage car rally is complete
without a trophy in this case 15
trophies for the best performance tests
and the most outstanding vehicles
[Music]
by the time they cross the finish line
the drivers are completely relaxed and
in the mood to celebrate the classic car
life with good food good music and good
company and bask in memories of bygone
days
[Music]
that's how this man compares his arrival
in couples to passing a guard of honor
people were lining the streets right and
left as if he were an athlete who'd won
a championship even so he was in a
supporting role because the cars
themselves were in the lead role and he
likes it that way
another points out that they didn't see
any stressed-out teams crossing the
finish line instead they saw people nice
and relaxed headed home after simply
enjoying life for a while that's the
idea behind hiking by vintage car he
says it's a good approach and hopes
organizers will keep the event going and
they've already said next year's route
in 2018
the rally will lead through the orange
spray Lake District
you